this is Danny Michael associate curator
of the Buffalo Bill center of the West
Cody Firearms Museum which hosts a wide
array of wild west Weaponry artifacts
and Relics today he's joining us to
break down just a few of the details and
objects found in the world of Red Dead
Redemption 2.
so I've I can't say that I've heard of a
hunter getting run over by a deer like
that
um it would be really painful uh deer
antlers are can be quite sharp I highly
recommend checking out the Buffalo Bill
Center the west and Cody Firearms Museum
all of that information will be in the
description below and consider this your
spoiler warning for the game if you've
not got around to playing yet and if
you're squeamish there will be some
hunting and skinning of Red Dead
Redemption 2's flora and fauna but
without further Ado let's see what a
wild west expert makes of Red Dead
Redemption 2.
so here we see uh jumping onto the train
from a horse that actual style of train
robbery probably was not that common if
it happened at all it's pretty hazardous
it's pretty hard to actually Gallop
alongside the train and jump on what
robberies did happen preferred to board
it at the station and travel along to a
convenient point or Force the train to
stop along the track somewhere rather
than jump up on the train from a moving
horse that kind of robbery is mostly
something we know from pop culture but
train robberies were probably actually
more common than bank robberies in the
west some of the reasons being that if
you could stop the train in the middle
of nowhere where there wasn't likely to
be law enforcement around you could have
a lot more time to sort of get the goods
and then get away less people noticing
and being able to do anything about it
and as I mentioned when we're talking
about Banks the West suffered from a
physical currency shortage so train cars
and shipments of fresh limited coins
from like the San Francisco or Denver
mints would be really really lucrative
targets that would have been tried
traveling by train and here we see a
depiction of maybe that more accurate
depiction where somebody where they get
the train to stop out in the middle of
nowhere I think the train probably would
have taken a little longer to stop they
didn't give it much distance but
certainly that would have been the
actual style that uh had you seen a
train robbery it would have looked more
like this or more like the gang boarding
the train ahead of time getting it to
stop in a remote location at a remote
time when they're not likely to face
opposition the moral of the story is if
you ever find yourself as a trained
conductor in 1870s and a masked man with
a gun is stopping your train uh don't
hit the brakes
and here the the gang gets in a little
bit of a fight with the guards on the
train as train robberies of course
happen companies running the railroads
uh started to arm the trains and and
Harden them a little bit better put more
armed guards on them hire detective
agencies like the pinkertons to protect
the trains to guard the trains
um and it was the sort of this ebb and
flow as uh robberies became more common
the train companies tried to put more
preventative measures in place
eventually as the West uh grew there
were fewer and fewer options for the
robbers became more and more difficult
so then you see train robberies really
declined by the late west so the the
period the game is set in train
robberies were starting to happen less
frequently although the 1890s there were
still I think
I think I've read that there are over
200 documented attempts at least
so we're seeing this town that is
obviously in crisis from a cholera
outbreak cholera was a pretty serious
disease in the old west and it could
really devastate a community especially
before they fully understood how
transmitted and what steps to take to
mitigate how it might spread so and
obviously in what would be a very
Frontier Town that's it's small most of
everything still wood structures and a
small community like this
if they if cholera started to spread
could spread very quickly
um and impact a big portion of the town
here we have Arthur looking through a
catalog he's looking at some Firearms
those kinds of things existed there were
catalogs for just about anything uh back
in the day and believe it or not there
are even advertisements for c96 Mausers
in the in the west so this kind of
catalog looks uh really well done
actually for the kind of catalogs that
you can find in archives and that kind
of thing the one thing they get wrong
are the prices the Firearms are wildly
too expensive that's also true for the
ammunition both are sort of inflated
over what they would have been at the
time oh like a brand new Winchester uh
when Arthur's sort of in the the game
time frame could be as little as 18 so
to see 60 70 80 or even over a hundred
dollars for some of these guns is is
pretty high by 1890 standards
so here we see Arthur looking at some
ammunition uh on the on the Shelf so the
gun store there they actually did a
pretty decent job of coming up with some
period looking boxes they're a little
bit too modern though the labeling and
the font is is sort of right uh style
but the colors are a little bit off it's
it's a very modern color palette uh more
accurate would be something like this
box it's not in the best condition
but if you can see it on screen there
that is for a Winchester 1873 cartridges
which would be 4440 so this is probably
what you would expect a commercial
ammunition box to look like maybe this
one's probably a little bit earlier than
the game setting the boxes that are a
little bit more plain sort of on the
Shelf there still look a little bit like
this this is a military cartridge box
from the period so this one's a lot more
uh plain there's no color to it but the
similar font so I think the ones that
are on the shelves are a little bit uh
closer to period than the one he's
holding but pretty well done examples of
what period cartridge boxes look like
so here we see him uh skinning the elk
um which is a pretty big job I've
actually hunted uh some myself and I
have skinned an elk in the field and
it's a lot of a lot of work but what
he's doing here is pretty accurate you
kind of have to roll the the skin back
and use a knife to pull that off not
everybody pulls the hide when they uh
hunt an elk because it's very heavy to
carry out so we see Arthur taking the
antlers here like a modern Hunter Mite
that was also done in the American West
people like to keep the antlers
sometimes use them for decoration and
sometimes maybe use them a little
someone more practically so Arthur
hunting here is pretty well depicted the
one thing that's probably not super well
depicted is just how much work it is to
actually do what he's doing there that
al-qaed probably weighs 60 or 70 pounds
with all the other stuff the other thing
that's not great of a depiction is that
you only get a few pieces of big game
meat off of every elk and actual elk a
hunter would expect to get something
like you know a couple hundred pounds of
meat off of
so I've I can't say that I've heard of a
hunter getting run over by a deer like
that it would be really painful uh deer
antlers are can be quite sharp but that
is something to remember back in the
1890s just as today animals in the west
are wild and they
will mostly run away from you because
they don't like humans that much but if
you if you force them to and they're
feeling you know if you Corner them or
threaten them they can fight back so
Arthur here hunting that deer and a
little bit more classic scene rather
than riding up to it sort of stocking up
in the grass and taking what's called a
broadside shot on the deer hitting it
near the shoulder pretty typical scene
both in the American West for a hunter
and in a modern day of course back in
the old west I talked about I'm just
getting the elk a little bit here he's
skinning the deer hide that Buckskin and
those alkides were used pretty
practically so they're kept probably
more often in the old west than they
were kept today but still a lot of stuff
to carry back on on his horse here so
when he skins the deer here the one
thing the game doesn't depict is that
when he skins the deers just to assume
that he sort of gutted the carcass if he
was actually taking good care of that
meat he would have fully gutted it but
obviously that's not something they
probably really want to show in video
game they have to make it a little bit
more simplified for harvesting an animal
like that even today people tend to take
mostly the meat maybe leave the hide
take the antlers so what he's depicted
doing here is a realistic scenario for
the old west as it is actually for the
modern West really
so here we see Arthur Jason down a bison
uh and and actually roping it I'm not
aware that that was done much maybe
somebody tried it in the west what's
really interesting about this clip is
the game is set in the late 1890s and at
this point in the U.S there's less than
a thousand uh bison in 1899 so the fact
that you can hunt them in game is a
little bit of an anachronism that
probably wasn't possible there probably
wasn't very much hunting opportunity for
bison at this point they had been over
hunted for most of the 19th century and
especially in the second half of the
19th century so by the 1870s is really
when you start to see the decline of the
of the big bison herds and by the 1880s
the numbers had dropped off really
sharply so that by the 1890s it would
have been pretty unheard of to even see
a bison in the west but Arthur here does
encounter one and attempts to rope it I
would most certainly get him kill build
hardly severely injured I would think
bison are incredibly strong animals
they're as fast as this horse they're
very heavy and they will not hesitate to
headbutt you if they feel threatened and
it happens to at least a few tourists
every year unfortunately so if you come
out to the west and you see a bison uh
maintain a safe distance one thing that
is probably accurate about this bison
hunting is that we see Arthur take a
shot with the bolt action rifle because
bison are such large animals they do
require a really well placed shot to
bring them down so the first shot there
kind of behind its head doesn't
necessarily kill it right away it does
wound it and he has to shoot it again
that would not be unheard of for an
animal this large especially in the west
they're just they're just really huge
huge animals
probably the other thing here that is a
little bit Arthur's on his own trying to
skin this and certainly it would be
possible but um absolutely would have
been a ton of work those bison can weigh
2 000 pounds 1500 pounds pretty easily
so they are hard to work with in the
in the field
foreign
really well the Mauser is modeled really
well it has all the features you might
expect and you can see Arthur aim down
the sights uh the sights on these
pistols are actually graduated out
really far they're really really
ambitious so this one is graduated out
to a thousand meters the pistol
cartridge that's firing would not
certainly not go that be effective at
that range but they are graduated that
far but the animations you see his
reloads and all those things are very
very accurate for how the gun is
manipulated so that's modeled really
really well one of the other things that
you'll notice is when Arthur reloads he
reloads from
a stripper clip just like this one so
these 10 rounds are fastened to a metal
clip and that metal clip inserts into
the top of the gun and then you push the
your thumb down on the rounds to push
them all into the magazine and so these
are original uh Mauser cartridges these
are c96 of the ammunition that he would
be using in game were real life I
mentioned these were sold in the in the
US and that you could see advertising
for these in the US and this is actually
a box of ammunition a period box of
ammunition
for the Mauser
um and you can see there that that is
still has its original two sets of 10
Rounds on stripper Clips so you could
order your ammunition on you could buy
the ammunition for this Mauser you could
buy it already on Clips or you could buy
it loose and it would come in uh these
really neat little boxes just like this
and then you can see there that is sold
um by the Remington Arms Union metallic
cartridge company uh so it's a very
American company that was selling that
ammunition so that was ammunition sold
in the US for the Mauser another piece
of that these guns were actually
available and are not too far off for
Arthur to be carrying them listen
I know this sounds crazy
some dumb old coot I know it's telling
me there's these houses you can buy
pre-cut not crazy friend the very latest
in modern convenience convenient and
cost efficient
so here we see
um John looking through a catalog for a
house and we talked about the way you
could order products from a catalog
before and actually what's being
depicted here is really
um is actually quite accurate so you
could open up a Sears catalog from that
time period and Order yourself a house
and they had different floor plans that
you could purchase different layouts so
they were not really fully customizable
but at least semi-customizable uh you
had a few different options that you
could order and then as courses you
built it if you wanted to modify it you
could and the way that this would work
is you put in your order as as he does
there and then the crates with all the
materials would be shipped to the
nearest rail head and then it was on you
to go pick them up from the rail head
and deliver them to wherever uh you
would be building so you'd bring in the
wagon load of supplies and you would get
the plans and they actually made housing
kind of a affordable option it was sort
of an easier option than some of the
other ways to to get yourself a house
built on the west and you had a pretty
reliable set of plans and actually in
most communities in America especially
older communities in America and using
old by American definitions and not owed
by European definitions but so anything
that was a town from around the 18 late
1800s to early 1900s you can often still
find these Sears frame houses around so
even Cody if you drive around if you
ever come to visit Cody Wyoming and you
drive around town there are probably at
least a half a dozen of these houses in
this town that are still standing some
have been modified a little bit some
have additions on them but at least a
couple are pretty close to their
original original footprint so yeah this
scene where he would have ordered a
house and brought it in and and
assembled it with himself and some
friends is certainly is an accurate way
to portray getting a house in the
American West in the late 1890s and the
music is very satisfying as you watch
and build a house
well let me have a rule and a song and a
board and I'll cut it
I'll climb up a ladder with a hammer and
nail now nearly
well we worked so hard to build a little
house together
if you'd like to see more of Danny as
well as other wild west episodes make
sure to like the video and let us know
in the comments I hope you'll join me in
thanking Danny and the Cody Firearms
Museum for collaborating with us on this
video you can check out some of their
videos as well as all of their other
information in the description below